hello thank you so much for um joining
this event my name is haruko nakamura
librarian for japanese study at yale
this is the second event of the special
lecture series east asian digital
collection digital humanities
co-sponsored by the east asia library
and the council of east asian studies at
yale university
i'd like to acknowledge the uh
generous funding support by the council
and i'm especially grateful for
stephanie kim the program coordinator
for the council for all the logistical
coordination of this event
if you have questions please type your
question
in a
q a session
q a box
and also this event is being recorded
and the video will be available via the
ces
channel later
so today i am delighted to have dr
asanovu
for today's talk uh leading
leading adult data driven approaches for
japanese studies
doctor kitamoto received his phd in
electronic engineering from the
university of tokyo currently he is the
director of the
roisds center for open data in the
humanities
and also a professor in digital content
and
media sciences
research division at the national
institute of informatics
and the graduate university for advanced
study so can die
dr kitamata has received numerous hours
such as the jury recommendation award
from japan media arts festival yamashita
research award from information
processing society of japan
and the best paper award from jim hong
kong uh symposium
and the academic award from the japan
society for digital archive
please join me uh welcoming dr pista
moto miroshkas
uh thank you very much for the
introduction uh so my name is assan of
guitar moto and director of royce diaz
center for bonnet and humanities
and professor of national institute of
informatics so as uh argos are uh
introduced my original background is is
informatics of computer science but i
started this humanities research
about 20 years ago and
recently my uh main focus of research is
uh digital humanities
so i'd like to introduce today
uh our activities in codh especially
in data-driven approaches for japan
studies
and
so reading edo we we are working on edo
period data and so i'd like to introduce
some of the projects that i am working
on in the edo period data
so uh the rose ds center for food data
in humanities
the acronym is codh
so uh you can access this url
to see what
our activities
and basically
what we're doing can be categorized into
two
one is data-driven humanities
which is uh focusing on innovation in
humanities research using computer
science technologies and tools
and another
category is humanity's big data
so it is
focusing on innovation in non-humanities
research using humanities data so uh
today i will introduce
those two research directions
and uh
so
our center is called open data so open
science is the keyword in our center
so uh open data is
is on on about uh open science is to
make the research more open
and uh so it's like
we are collaborating scholars and
machines and citizens collaborate each
other to expand the knowledge and
increase our knowledge and deepen the
knowledge so this is what we are doing
in codh
and as open data represents we we
release
many types of open data sets and this is
available in this url
so um
this pre-modern japanese text which is
the are digitized books of
uh primordial japanese books uh
which was originally digitized by
national institute of justice literature
and we
host the state distribution of data you
know from our website
and we create many derivative datasets
from from these
classical books like edo cooking recipes
which is a
one or three egg dishes
with the recipes
with recipes and photographs created by
professional
cooking
researchers
so this is beautiful pictures and you
can reproduce the the cooking by
yourself
so
and also
when we started codh
national institute of judgment
literature
uh also started as a big project called
a network project
and the purpose of this project is to
digitize as 300 000 pre-modern japanese
books which is uh before 1868 or the edo
period
and they're digitized and released as
open data
so
the advantage of data
is that anyone can use data for any
purpose uh only requirement is to give
attribution to national institution
literature so uh
with this project
japanese culture finally entered into
the big dead era so this is a
appropriate time to start data-driven
approaches to japanese japan studies
so i'd like to introduce some of the
projects that we have been doing and the
first one is ai crc recognition from the
data set to the app and this project is
a collaborator is stan kalanwat who was
originally a formerly a cod researcher
and now
is working on in google brain
so uh the purpose so the motivation of
the research is
this uh dissidation of the books and uh
if you can see the books uh you can
understand that japanese knowledge of a
thousand years
is uh recorded in in the
massive amount of books
so these are how to wear
makeup or how to fold 100 cranes using
one piece of paper we call it origami in
japanese and also how to build automata
or robots in other period so it's like
um
any kind of knowledge that existed in
the past is recorded in the books so we
like to take advantage of this knowledge
uh but
the
the main problem
a big a big problem here
is the characters
that is recording the knowledge
so these are called kuju cg but uh
unfortunately
most of the japanese people uh including
me cannot read these good cities so
uh even if you decide the books uh and
releases as open data
most people cannot take advantage of
this knowledge in the books
so
the problem is that we have massive
documents but very few readers
and some people estimate that we have
one billion documents
still preserved in in japan before a
period
so um we have
quite a large number of documents
and but we have about 10 000 readers
who who can read fluently kudushi
so
this is quite an
unbalanced situation
for example in english you have probably
many documents but many readers so you
can
many people can read
the english characters so you can for
example ask the
citizens to read uh documents using uh
crowdsourcing or so on but in in in
japanese kurdish documents we
have many but we have
few readers so we cannot take advantage
of these documents
so
we think that
um
ai or machine learning is a solution for
to solve this problem
so uh we created produces data set
and uh well this this data set is
created by nasa leader institute of
japanese literature and we created the
data set and releases as open data
so
as you can see this is the collection of
cd character
um
this is no
hiragana no
in
the collection of hiragana no and uh so
for each character we collected a
character from many books and uh
and and uh organized it
by characters
and so the open data consists of
character types
4328 character types and
we have more than one million character
shapes
so uh
this is a quite large uh data set and
if you can if you can download the zip
file
uh you can use it as training data for
machine learning
and so you can
develop a accuracy recognition using
this uh training data
and so the release of data set
stimulated research on accuracy
recognition and our group is one of them
so using this data set we can
develop ax recognition
uh but what kind of technology is useful
for this problem
and we think that
uh the the technology called object
detection is useful for this for this uh
to solve this problem
and this object detection is developed
in the in the research field called
computer vision so it's basically
analyzing the image
using uh algorithms
and especially object detection is a
vibrant research area
with industrial values such as
autonomous driving so if you can see
this image the object detection
algorithm can detect that this area we
have a car and we have a car we have a
car here and we have bicycle or we have
traffic light and so on so you can
easily guess that this is very useful
for autonomous driving so
many people are working on object
detection algorithms and so we have a
very good algorithm for object detection
so the idea is that can we apply this
technology for kudosi characters like
this
and well this is a simple idea this
sounds like to be a simple idea but it
was not possible before and we tried it
and
and unexpectedly successful result we
get
so uh the results
we developed the
method called kuronet
it is a crucial recognition using deep
learning method
and uh so the if you
well you can see that their kuzu cg and
uh
well the kuzu city
you can
these are written uh and in a connected
style so
well each character is not separated
some a few characters are sometimes
connected so it is not easy to divide
into one character
but the using coronet you can
uh
detect the character like this so this
this rectangle is called bounding box uh
so you can see that well even even the
character is connected they it can
divide into
well for example here you can divide it
into each character
and then you
recognize the character in the bounding
box so you can
see that these are
unicode characters that is used uh
in the modern japanese so starting from
kudzu cg character you can first detect
the bounding box and then
recognize characters
and so then we can read
and any japanese can read like these
characters
so
and we we it takes only one or two
seconds for to
to recognize all the characters in one
image so it is
is fast enough and accuracy is is
sometimes 95 for books with the best
condition
so
even if we have some some several uh
errors in one image we can still
understand that what is written in in
one page so it is very helpful for
japanese to understand what is
the content of the books
so this is a example of a exclusive
recognition and uh
[Music]
let's start
so uh
when
you can see the chronic policy
recognition service is here and this is
i will explain later that this is called
the triple creation viewer
and
if if the books are
distributed or delivered
using triple if you can
use this viewer and
specify the box that you want to
recognize
to cg and you can
after that you can move to uh
crucifixion service
and in one in a few seconds
you can see that
the characters are recognized like this
so you can zoom in or zoom out and you
can also change the location or the size
of the characters
uh the location of the characters
and
so on so that you can
compare the modern character with
acoustic character and then you can
uh
yes and also you you can have a clone
text editor to
specify
the reading order of the characters
and after that
you can
out
output the text reading of
the of the page
yes
so
then you can copy and paste this text
into
um
editor or so on so you can take
advantage of this text
service
so um
using this service you can
first capture the image and then
and recognize and
and serialize and finally you get text
okay
so we developed chronet
but we want to improve that we wanted to
improve
uh the machine learning model to a more
higher performance
so we used uh
cargo
which is the largest ai competition
platform
so we hope we had a competition called
code city recognition
in on cargo and our convention was the
first in the humanities domain
so we release data set and ask
ai experts in the world
to submit
a good model for air accuracy
recognition
so uh yeah we also provide the price
money like this
and the period was from july to october
2019 and uh we had 293 teams uh with 338
members and they submit to more than 2
000
submissions
so
as a result of this
worldwide competition
we get a very good model uh from
many people
and uh the winner model kota cj
team
looks like this so if you give a kuzu cg
book
then they can detect the boundary modes
like this
and uh
it's
um
the top accuracy was uh 95
so this is quite remarkable because well
the characters are mixed with figures
illustrations
but they can
uh
mostly they can detect only characters
but not not
illustrations like this
so
even in under the quite complex layout
again
the the algorithmic detector character
safely uh uh
with a quite high accuracy
and a remarkable point is that
all winners do not read kujochi but
have developed good machine learning
models so or good uh accuracy
recognition models
so
uh
just focusing on developing a accuracy
recognition
they don't need
they need they don't have to read
khrushchev by human the machines can
read it
but the import also the important point
is that well the domain knowledge we
need to have a domain knowledge about
kudus what is because
how we can create a data set for machine
learning we need a very good domain
knowledge and so in other words the
domain knowledge was embedded in a data
set so the machine ai researchers do not
have to have the domain knowledge of
procedure
so
it's like open innovation we ask people
to to develop good models and then we
get
this
models for
wide use
and after this
we started developing a app for air
accuracy recognition called mio and so
we we also we already released the uh
ecosystem chronic policy recognition
service for triple f images
but
uh
well sometimes it is more convenient if
you can use your mobile phone to take a
photograph and
then definitely because she's in the
photograph
it's more convenient and especially
convenient if you
if you need to study the material on
site
move go somewhere and take a photograph
and study the document in the
old house or temple or so on
so this the app is developed for that
purpose
and the meanwhile the name of mio comes
from the fourteenth chapter of the tale
of genji miyotsukushi
referring to waterway science so this is
ukiyoe
showing the the meevo
tsukushi
this uh
this shape is
is miyutsukushi
and so just as miyazuku sees the guide
for both in the sea we aim to make our
new app as a guide for traveling the
ocean of historical documents so this is
why we name it mio
so
this is a
prototype app
prototype version
which is used at the chemical museum in
april 2021 so you can see that well we
have bubble here
and just take a photograph of bioblue
and then mule app can recognize
characters on the on build
so it doesn't have to be a very uh a
flat
flat book it's like um
you can just take a photograph and if
it's a little
slanted you can still
recognize characters on them on the
billboard
so this is you can see that this is
quite useful to
to
recognize krishiji uh
at the site
and now the muo app has this interface
the release version has this interface
so you can show a regulation result in
characters or you can show
a regression result with bounding boxes
like this
and you can also swipe
to compare the original book and the
recognition result
and also you can
well sometimes ai has errors so you can
you want to modify
the reference
results and
[Music]
we have this interface and also with
reference to root characters
to
or also
see the database of exclusive characters
and then understand that well probably
this is
wrong and another one is correct
and finally you can also
generate the text output from the
existing result so you can copy and
paste to another uh
another application so that you can use
it for your research or for for other
purposes
so uh we summarize the impact and
feature of cluster recognition
so the mio app was downloaded more than
42 000 times
and more than 300
000 images were recognized since the
release
and the daily uploaded images is
constantly above 2000 images so
this indicates that the app is used
steadily
and there's demand from the public
to recognize called cg
and
so we
released the app but
i think the future
is
that
we want to develop the full text search
engine of historical documents
like google google or google books you
can search
type the word and search the books
and well we don't have such full text
search engine for history documents of
japanese
and so we would like to develop this in
a in a few years
and we already have the name for this
food exergent it's called tsukushi so
it's like mio and tsukushi so tsukushi
part it would be useful to search engine
and i think i believe that the full text
search engine would be the driver of
digital transformation in the humanities
research especially japan studies
because full text search engine you can
see the detail of the books and then
starting starting from the
detail you can expand the search so i
think that this is a very
important
tool
for
digital transformation in humanities
research
okay so i would like to move on to the
next uh topic uh of about book and
complete collection
so uh this collaborator is gonna become
designer uh professor christiane in the
national institute of japanese
literature so um
we talk about character recognition and
well it's
after character recognition accuracy
recognition you can analyze the text
but um and
usually these two humanities people
focus more on text
because it is the human humanities
research they are quite
uh
focusing on
text interpretation or text
understanding or text to critical
reading or so on
but in
in the digital humanities we need to
focus on not also non-textual
materials like images and photographs
and maps and about the character
recognition and so on
so
i'd like to emphasize that this document
is not only about text
and
so from now on we introduced uh how to
deal with structured data or
unstructured data
and unstructured data is includes a
visual and spatial sources like
photographs it's
well it's a pixel a collection of pixels
on the maps it's also the
images or data but
it's
uh not
text
so they require its own analysis
interpretation framework so we are also
working on developing this kind of
framework for non-textured sources
um
so the bookcan i would like to introduce
the program project um what we
which is about a non-textual or
structured data project
and this is an example of bukhan book
which is published in 1789
including included in the data set of
pre-modern japanese text
so you can see that well this is
actually
information about daimyo
in the other period and this is
called crest or camo
it's a symbol of a family
and also this is the name of the daimyo
and this also includes when they go to
edo or then when they return to their
home country
home state or
what they give to bakufu or how what
kind of
uh tools they use for
making uh
and as a symbol of the family or so
and also these are the
names of uh
important persons
in uh in the daimyo family uh that i'm
your state
so this is a quite a structured data and
the buchanan is a kind of data book of
daimyo and personal in the bakufu
um
so this has a rich kind of information
and an interesting point is that this
bookcam book has been published for more
than 200 years before 1867
until the end of end of the year period
so we have actually many versions of
bookcon
and
and also from several publishers
and also it's it's a long set of books
actually it has been published for 200
years because it is important and long
seller
and it's it has practical usage like
if some people use it as a souvenir from
edo city or some people use it for
seeing the daimyo george
procession of the emir uh to
that these
tools uh can be used to identify which
family is is working so
so and because of the the large demand
the frequency of updates had increased
to a few times a month at peak so
it is uh it has
so if you compare a different version
you you can identify that which part is
updated from the previous version to the
next
so this kind of free
frequency frequent update of the
information is also an interesting point
of lucam books
and from from the spoken books you can
create uh some visualization or the
structured
data
like this is the sankin quota animation
sunken quota is that
daimyo needs to
move from the their home country to edo
and
back
they have to move back and forth
because of the order of the bakufu so
they and so it's the animation of when
they move to it or when they leave it
also
and also this is uh information
extracted from the bootcamp that it has
some properties of daimyo like how many
rice
crops they can produce or
where they live or so on
so this kind of structured data can be
created from book and books
but the problem is that
well this is quite heavy work
and as i said
we have books over 200 years so how we
can
how can we transcribe
all of them
and well it's it's not realistic to
transcribe all of them
so
the solution is that
well
why not detect and transcribe the
difference to create time series data
so we call it differential transcription
because well if you compare this
book and
another book
you can see that well most of the part
looks like
the same but some part for example this
uh
family
tree the
this part is absent here and this
character is also here but not here so
there's difference between the two
versions so you can probably identify
the difference and then transcribe
the updated part
to create time series data
so uh
well the idea is that
if you have text you can easily compare
the text a and text b and find
difference and there are many tools
available for
identifying the textbook difference
but for for using this textbook
difference we need to transcribe or we
need to apply ocr to get text from the
image and then compare but this is not
realistic for the book and books because
some characters difficult to read and
and also we have a graphical element
which is not character like this
so
the idea is that we develop an image
based or non-textual difference by
directly comparing the images and find
the difference
and unfortunately there are no standard
tools available for this purpose
and the traditional method is
side-by-side comparison so we put two
images side by side and compared by
human eyes
but is there any
better way
so it's like visual comparison
and it's called find the difference game
so you can compare two images and i
detect the difference
but this is quite difficult and
well actually
it is difficult so it is a game
so
not easy but if you use if you can take
advantage of the
the computer
computer can overlay two images and and
uh emphasize the difference and then you
can easily identify that well this part
is different this spot is different this
part this part
those parts are different so
it's not
difficult so it's not a game it's it's
it's easy game for computers
so the important point is that for
humans visual comparison requires an
effort comparable to playing games
it's not it's difficult but for machines
visual comparison is an easy game
using computer vision based image
matching algorithm
so um
let's turn a difficult task reading
difference into an easy one with the
help of machines
so
if we provide uh humans with this figure
humans can easily identify that well
this part is diffic different
so
instead of showing these two images
we create this image and show show it to
humans and then they can identify the
difference so we call it differential
reading
so it's a new mode of reading books
focusing on difference between additions
or versions
and we released a service called image
collation for differential reading on
this url
so it we developed a javascript base to
relieve the js for comparing images
and for on this website you anyone can
upload two images or specify urls
and the system can automatically match
two images and differentiate the
difference
and when the system fails you can
manually improve the matching
so uh
and uh
this this kenti hacking issue comparison
this is not released by us but
it's released from the university of
tokyo library
and they compare uh genji hacking issue
images from two different libraries
and compare them on the brilliant.js.js
that we provide
and then they under they notice that
there's difference on this part
but characters are the same but only the
facial part is has difference so we
don't know why they are different but it
is an interesting observation and it is
not easy to to notice by humans by just
comparing side by side but
overlaying two images you can easily
identify that well there is actually
difference so why there's difference it
is a new research question that
to ask
for
and study more about how the books are
created and so
and the this image collection service is
for two images but for the book on we
want to compare books or book collection
so
we develop a system for book correlation
uh and a large-scale book collection
correlation
so
i like briefly introduce how we do this
and it's it's consists of page
correlation book collection and workbook
tracking
the first part is page correlation so we
compare two images and overlay two
images using key point matching
and keyboard i don't go into the detail
about the algorithm but basically we
detect the key points like this which is
kind of has a unique uh
intensity change in in a small region
and then
com compare two images that
has similar key points
and then make a
correspondence between key points and
then
compute how we can overlay two images
with uh minimum error
so this using this algorithm you can
compare two images
and also in a book level we we
compare book for
each page from book a and then each base
from book b and
see that how many key points we can make
make a matching
and then we can
order by score
and apply the stable
marriage algorithm to find the best
match so stable marriage algorithm
basically have a preference
it's originally developed for the
optimal
marriage between the men and women
and
the requirement is that each men and
women has a preference order that
this
this
lady a has preference on
three five two one four
men and so on
so if we define this preference order
then we can find the
best uh matching mismatch
so we apply this algorithm for making a
best match between book and book b
so uh this is an example of a
page by page collation so you can see
that what this part
is red is from the this book published
in
1991 and the blue part is from the
1789 so they're two years apart
and
and then you can see that some parts are
missing in
blue book and some parts are missing in
red book and you can easily identify
that
this
which part is updated in
two versions
and also you can have one image showing
the difference easily
by
using red and blue color and if if the
matching is not good then you can change
in real time the how
we improve the matching between two
images
so uh
after this we can keep tracking of the
wood block across time
so for example this book is published in
1809
and this book is published in 1841 so
it's
the difference but you can overlay two
images and then compare the difference
so the same rulebook can be tracked to
analyze the evolution of information on
the boot block and this is useful for
a differential transcription to identify
the difference and then transcribe that
part
okay so we move to the third part uh
calculate entry point creation platform
and this collaborator is chica suzuki
and june homma and intel
so i'd like to introduce the triple if
which is
maybe some of you have already known the
the triple if but
this triple f is called international
image interpreted framework
and
well
to understand easily
i sometimes say that
on the web you have html
and if you create html page
you can
have many
web service
one two three and you can if you use the
web browser
you can see
all the web
service using one viewer and one browser
and
you have uh
several browsers like chrome
and edge and firefox and so on
but using another
different browser you can
use this web service
everywhere
using the same browser
so
gpi feeds
is html
four images
so you have many three five servers in
the world
and you have a few uh triple f viewer
but if you've have used one 35 viewer
then you can see
any type of service
using one viewer
so
uh
i introduced some of the uh information
about tripolif in this code seminar but
this is yes you can understand that this
is images uh triple f is like
web in html in the web
and we are interested in using two pi
for curation
and creation is a word that originally
means activities of museums such as
collecting materials and exhibiting
artworks
so we if we have um
so it's like a process of collecting
materials under certain theme and
arrange them in an appropriate order or
layout and present or share the result
as a new material so this is a step of
curation
and if we want to create a curation like
the collection of faces
in analog
age
we need to take a
photograph or copy the material and
using scissors to crop
the part
and use the glue to
collect them in a new as a new
collection
so it is a very time-consuming work in
analog world
but in a digital world you can
create a collection quite easily
using triple escalation viewer which is
developed by cod since 2016.
so you can read a triple f image and you
can first use this rectangle
button crop button to select the region
and then use the star favorite button to
in input into creation to correct the
intercuration
so if you read
new triple images and
crop the region and then add to curation
and
by doing this you can create your own
collection of images from the other part
of image
so using this approach we created a
collection of facial expressions of
calculate a cow is face and collar is a
collection so
with this as a new data set for facial
expressions so using triple f creation
viewer for cropping and collecting part
images and we use another tool called
triple creation finder for searching the
collection by metadata like this is a
image of warriors
which is added as a metadata of these
books these images
and
finally we use triple creation board for
analyzing collection for art history
research
in the digital humanities
research
so uh this
type of creation board you can
well first we
create a use a triple creation viewer to
crop those regions and use create a
calculator collection and then use two
calculation boards to
organize images in on 2d two-dimensional
board
and you can
place for example this um
sheet mat or to make a grouping or add a
stamp
to
add another more
smaller
groupings of the
images and so on
so you can move these images to another
group or so on so that these are
actually uh the criteria of using art
history research that
how to study this book and you can
because this is triple with you can
anytime go back to the original image to
understand the in which context that
this face appears
so it's like you can go you can first
study the detail of the face and then
return to the uh
or the macro
scale analysis is including the context
of the face
and we also developed a phase detection
by machine learning which is similar to
the kudushiti character
so the same technology can be applied to
face detection in the artwork
and these are
the algorithms successfully i didn't
detect the phases in artworks
learned from the calculated data set
so this is a like a machine learning
assisted annotation so it's like
learning from the calculator data set
about 80 percent of the face is
automatically detected and if we apply
it this technology to
new artworks is still
detected in 70 of the faces
so
it means that
two-thirds of the faces can be
automatically detected
so the amount of work by humans is
reduced to one third
then other histories and can analyze
more data and more data leads to richer
evidence and higher reliability of the
results so it's like
using machine learning and
create a new data set this is
useful for expanding the the data set
sites
and
useful for art history research
and
another technology for face detection is
used to create utili faces data set
which is created by uh
intel tn from google brain
and
well the original image is from art
research center it's mecca university
and uh
well it's it's a uk
[Music]
and kabuki player it makes mostly kabuki
player and uh
player faces are extracted and and
organized by the author of the
paintings so you can it is released as a
new data set for visualization
okay the final topic is edomaps adobe
and historical big data and collaborated
so this is edomaps beta uh
we this atom up is actually created by
the at the end of edo period and
it is a very detailed map with a
with a
town name and streets and
kennels and so on
so uh there are many place names and so
from 29 sheets we extracted 80
719 place names
and to create a database of place names
in the city
so we create
uh we explain how we created the map
so the original image is is uh released
from the digital collection of national
diet library of japan
as a triple ef image
so using triple f you can add value by
adding information without copying
original images so you can overlay the
annotation
like well this
place we have this uh name and this
places has name like this
so
read the image
on the triple creation viewer draw a
rectangle to record the coordinate and
then transcribe characters inside the
rectangle
and save them using the triple creation
format using this approach we can create
a database of place names with the
coordinate on the map
but
if we use the maps we will also want to
know the
uh coordinate of the current on the
current map or in another word latitude
and longitude of the place
so as you can see that well this map is
not like
the current map it's it's distorted and
north is not on up
so
we use the uh rich maker university map
warper for japanese and
add a
correspondence of gcp ground control
point that this point is this point on
the map or so
then we use this to
make a geo reference of the maps
so uh
repeat this process for 29 maps well we
understand that the those edo curious
map is covering this area of the tokyo
current tokyo
and uh the extractive place names are
like this so we have cities residents
temples and shrines shopping sites place
names 12 names what area size things
suppose others there are many other
place names that are not transcribed
especially the uh the name of the
baku
bakufu people which is quite large so
we
only extracted some of the place names
in the in the maps but it is useful for
identifying that
uh important place names in nato city
and after your referencing we can
overlay
uh previous old maps on the current map
using google earth and you can see that
well this is tokyo seat
station and this is imperial palace and
imperial palace is previously edo castle
and also the channels are now
some of the cannons are turned into the
road now but still
the the
road in dado period is still used as a
road in the modern
city and it is interesting to see this
and
the edo maps can be used
and in this
way
you can see the list of edo maps and
then you can see
the the
the map
with a marker
on the with the name transcribed
text
if you can click you can see that for
this part this point is like this
and so on
you we also use the tripod creation
viewer to visualize the
this the old map as a kind of web map
and you can also see the information for
each individual place names
and after that we create a
we use the geo lod which is a
system to give an identifier for
toponyms or place names
so each place name has a unique
identifier
and
so and the jiod has a is a database
to have a unique identifier and also the
name and that is longitude
extracted from the geo reference map
so uh using this deleted id identifier
we can
specify the place name across the
different
applications
and
for example we created the edo
sightseeing guide
we selected two tribal guidebooks for
each century and used triple creation
viewer to crop pictorial parts and added
metadata by transcription so and
assigned geolody and other identifiers
so this is a
image of asakusa and uh
yes you we give an identifier duality
identifier to
this image so we can use this
image in another application to show the
image of asakusa
we also created a shopping guide and uh
yes it's like the database of shopping
guide books published in 1824
and yeah we classified the type of
merchant's business according to this
system and assigned jewelry and identify
it so we can know that this this is the
place of the shops and then we know that
which area we have uh this kind of
food uh
wholesale shops and so on
and
now those information is integrated into
adobe data portal for history called edo
and
so we can visualize that where the
distribution of the shops
and
sightseeing spots on the current map
so it's like looking back the history
so we uh well the for the example
shopping guide we created the type
classification of the business
using the current japan standard
industrial classification
so then we know that well notice we have
many medicine shops and household
hardware and so on so uh we can easily
understand that how the business
distribution is worth in edo period
and
the reason of doing this is that
well
we believe that the general public wants
to look back the history from the
present so it is easier to understand
using the current
classification scheme
and
well we know that experts try to
understand the past as it was so they
tried to study the material
as it was but
we would write link
the
past from the present to
to
understand for the general public to
understand more easily
so uh
similar idea is actually explored in the
europe called time machine europe
project
and they call it big data of the past
so they create a machine readable date
of the past using air and simulation and
developing new critical reflections the
past and the future
so it's like we
want to create a
picture of the past
and then connect it
with the present and then extend it to
the future and i think that is the very
important direction of the future
research
so we are working on historical big data
project it's like creating a structured
data from historical sources
on the nat nature data and cultural data
including whether earthquake eruption
disease
economy population politics and culture
and this is very
extracting
information on the past and use it for
the present and the future
so
the key point is data structure workflow
starting from handwritten characters to
digital image and plain text and by
transcription and by markup to
semi-structured data but then we also
want to analyze with the current
world like latitude and longitude so we
like to make a mapping between the
document space and entity space i
don't have time to expect the details so
just to show that the figure but the
important point is that we we like to
create link make a link between the
document and in the world
so this is a summary of today's talk uh
we introduced the data-driven approaches
for japan studies so the first project
is accuracy recognition it illustrates
how machine learning project can be
studied and developed into the real
world
application
and google complete correction shows how
the idea of differential reading can
reduce the button of humans
and the third one calculate demonstrates
that how interoperability such as
tripoli plays a critical role in this
documentary's platform
and finally the adam maps and historical
big data explorers the possibilities for
linking the past present and future
okay thank you very much
so
if you are interested visit our website
and also collaboration is welcome
thank you
thank you so much uh mr kitamoto um
it was very informative and i enjoyed it
a lot um i have
i myself i have a question but we only
have like uh very few minutes and i'm
thinking and the uh if any of you who
wants to
stay little longer i'm gonna extend uh
this event for five minutes so if you
have um
any question please do uh type in your
question and also the um actually i
think there's a function
you can raise hand to ask if you uh if
you don't want to type but um somebody
asked one person to ask about if it's
recording is available and yes it is um
unfortunately we were able to get
this recording so we will make it uh
uh
make it available through the uh council
of researchers east asia studies um at
the els channel um so
it's gonna take a little longer a little
while two weeks two weeks maybe but it
will be available um
oh there's no function sorry there's no
function for raising hands so you have
to sorry you have to type in a
question
and then now we have we got one question
is there any question you have please
let me know
um uh okay i have one question
um
okay so one question is from john uh
john damico uh thanks for the very
informative presentation will it be
possible to train the meal model on
other data sets groups of manuscripts
okay thank you very much for the
question uh well this is not currently
possible but
in the future we would like to
uh add a new data from uh
and
and
update the model for a new data set but
it's um
and also
probably we can
release the the
open source version in the future so
that you can use your own data set and
use it for your purpose but yeah this is
just a plan now
thank you thank you um another question
is thank you for the wonderful
presentation
i want to ask uh
what uh the future direction and or
current project for codh if you are in
position to share thank you again uh
this is from bianca
okay thank you very much uh this
this is not
easy to answer but well the the current
project the project that i introduced
today is ongoing so
well at least
this project is not finished we are
continuing this these projects and
probably we will introduce new projects
in the future but it's up to
uh what kind of
people we have in in our group or what
kind of collaboration we
can have so it's like up to
the future possibilities so it's not
like fixed plan
thank you okay
thank you thank you uh this is from
michael fountain
um i was curious to hear more about the
full text database uh you are trying to
build
how will you select the text
okay that's a good question
i think the uh the full text search is
for the um
general uh purpose so we don't uh select
uh
we don't have a selection policy or
correction policy i think the more
important point is that uh what the the
accuracy of the causal recognition and
the
full text generation so it's like if if
it seems to be a low quality probably we
don't include it and it seems to be high
quality we include so i think it
depends more on the quality of the
the machine learning rather than the
quality of the text
that that's my current idea
okay thank you um so we we we could get
i think this is from mr nakamura um
thank you for your lecture of professor
vitamoto my question is
is once you have enough number of data
for uh
is it possible to identify the certain
artist or scripture when the machine
sees the sultan faces or characters
okay thank you very much for a good
question i think yes and many people ask
a similar question like this
and uh currently
our focus is on detecting the object but
not the identify
the
artist or scripta uh
because i think it's it's not easy to
identify the person
it's like a we need a different level of
analysis so
but i i understand that this has a very
important
there's a large needs for this purpose
so
i want to work on this problem in the
future but not probably not now
but yes
and also uh and similar questions that
how to identify the fake
fake work rather than yeah the actual
work and that's also a very important
problem but
it's it's not easy to do this so
or maybe in the future thank you very
much yes
thank you
it's it's great to keep hearing feedback
i think um you know what people needs
and all that kind of thing
um so other question is uh this is uh
from uh
daniel bossman uh those tools are
amazing what do you think the most
significant new discovery has been from
the development of those remarkable
tools
uh okay yeah it's an important question
i think it's
um
well currently uh
so
our tool is to
uh
speed up the research of these uh
humanities
uh and
i think the uh
well the next step is that
humanity scholars are actually using
this tool to have deeper
knowledge uh from
from the from the data and that process
is well has just started so not not uh
like not making a significant progress
and well i think the the most uh
advanced two uh
phase is in calgary that actually the
art histories are using these tools to
understand that how many artists
actually drawing those figures or how
many groups are drawing these facial
faces
and well that analysis is done manually
by human scholars but will take
advantage of the large data sets we
create by the 3.2
and yes so it's like
relatively currently it's like a
confirmation of the existing knowledge
and also
extending that knowledge to a little
degree so
it's still not remarkable but i think we
are
making progress toward that direction to
make a significant discovery i think
this is very important for district
humanities so
we are
trying to do this
in the future
yeah i had a similar question about the
you know like
the tools like differential readings and
you know whatever the people start
finding do you do you leave it um
leave it open to for other people's to
see the difference and
all the kind of things
yes i i want to do this i want to
release it it as a
kind of derived data set from bukang
collection and yes actually for example
uh one researcher uh we are
collaborating with one researcher who
who wants to know how the thunking code
type period has changed over the period
and that kind of
data is not available now so
sometimes the time you change the
thinking of the season
at some year but we don't know the
detail so we can
recreate this data times this data from
the books and then probably it's uh
gives more a new knowledge from
[Music]
big data so i think we are
working on that direction
so and and after that we released this
result as a open date new open data set
thank you thank you uh we have two more
questions uh could you talk
talk a bit about the kingdom ocr project
such as
whether the application is still being
updated and whether the whether more
modern magazine data are added to train
the model thank you it's from uh
kropan
okay thank you for the question uh
yeah i didn't introduce this project but
we have a king diocer project which is
for the ocr for modern
modern meiji or taisho era
magazine books and so on and this is
another challenging
part
and it's different from kudzu city but
still difficult because of the
complexity of the character shapes and
also the
ruby and those additional
texture elements which is quite
bad for ocr
so
yeah we are developing uh we are
developing a version two of these
software and also we are
now working on creating a new data set
and but actually um it's not
only our pro our team that is working on
this kind of ocr project and actually
national diet library is currently
working on a bigger scale on developing
kinder ocr software and
they will release open source version
by the end of march
so this is another project it's not our
project it's another project but yeah
we are making in japan in japan uh we
are making big progress on this
software so maybe you can also refer to
the information from national guide
library about this ocr
that's great thank you so much and um
last is the uh actually it is good
closing uh question and it's from uh
professor danny boston um
uh if
i'm curious to ask a personal question
how did you first get into interested in
digital humanities
yeah thank you for uh
yeah interesting question and
yeah um
well in the beginning for example the in
my current uh in my
phds work
there's no
there's no element in this to humanity
so i
started the digital humanities research
after i started to work in in nia
national institute of informatics
and yeah i think it's it's like a
coincidence and uh yes because i well
there was a big this humanities project
i called distract and i was involved in
in a project
by
because i was asked from the boss that
you should work on this project so
i was involved in this project in that
way so
it's not like a plan
i was asked from the boss and then but i
think i was a little i had some
knowledge about
history and so on because i liked it so
well uh yeah at that time
not only me but other people uh put into
this project but other people left and i
was the only one that is
staying in was staying in a project so
then i continue
this risk but it's not like uh
sometimes i
i was thinking about leaving these
documents research into other areas
but
finally i
i keep staying on in the rese in this
area and finally i started this center
and
being more actively involved
that's great thank you so much again i
really thought i i think everybody saw
this was very informative and then very
interesting presentation um thank you so
much for all attending and then please
welcome uh
please thanks again join me for thanking
again um
thank you thank you very much thank you